so new york governor andrew cuomo is
weak he's been weakened by all the sex
harassment stories so the ideologues in
the state are
bending him to their will government has
to announce that the state will
distribute
up to fifteen thousand six hundred
dollars to quote undocumented immigrants
who lost
work during the pandemic it's not clear
what kind of id these
undocumented immigrants people who have
no respect for our country or here
illegally
what are they going to provide to show
that they're undocumented or
entitled to payment what is clear is all
this is going to cost new york more than
2 billion
the question is who's going to live
there actually after all this kind of
nonsense colin schmidt thinks about that
he's a state assemblyman in new york and
a candidate for congress
he joins us now schmidt thanks so much
for coming on i'm sincerely worried i
mean this
for real who's going to stay in new york
when they start doing things like this
absolutely tucker this is a disaster for
new york taxpayers
we have governor cuomo and the albany
democrats
ramming through a budget which is going
to provide up to fifteen thousand six
hundred dollars
in free taxpayer cash to illegal
immigrants
they're going to raise taxes four
billion dollars to help pay for it
and tucker the kicker on top of it this
budget also gives
the governor's appointed budget staffer
just the staffer unilateral
power to reduce local police department
state funding by up to 50 percent
if he does not they do not comply with
the governor's new policing mandates
people are being forced to leave new
york and this is example
number one
what i mean how in just really quick
what's the thinking here
that you know illegal immigrants illegal
aliens have suffered more than citizens
like why in the world would u.s
taxpayers owe someone breaking our laws
15 000
it is an affront to new york taxpayers
and it's really just shows that governor
cuomo who's engulfed in scandal
is not capable of leading the state he's
under immense political pressure
and he's using money out of taxpayers
wallets
to try to cling to power to appease the
furthest left fringes of the state
legislature
to really try to hold on to a seat
that's exactly they did the exact same
thing to governor blackface clan robes
in virginia he didn't resign and then
the lunatics just descended on him like
jackals and made him their marionette
they're due to joe biden are you going
to stay in new york
i'm staying in new york i'm fighting for
my home state we
we should always be the empire state
cuomo and
the radical left have turned us into the
exodus state but
i'm gonna stay and fight and i'm gonna
be introducing in the coming days
a bill to repeal this free taxpayer cash
for illegal immigrants fund it's it's
completely unacceptable especially in
this pandemic
when so many of our taxpayers are
suffering or out of work or having
trouble
meeting ends meet paying their mortgage
putting food on the table yeah i mean
this just shows you how backwards the
priorities are
it is it is we'll see in florida thank